well so so the
the the key thing to think about with uh
with programming languages and you think
about what a programming language is
there for is
it's about making a human more
productive right and so like there's an
old i think it's a steve
jobs quote about um it's a bicycle for
the mind
right you can you can you can definitely
walk
but you'll get there a lot faster if you
can bicycle on your way
and a programming language is a bicycle
for the mind yeah
it's uh wow that's a really interesting
way to think about it by raising the
level of abstraction now you can fit
more things in your head
by being able to just directly leverage
somebody's library you can now
get something done quickly um in the
case of swift swift ui
is this new framework that apple has
released recently for doing ui
programming
and it has this declarative programming
model
which defines away entire classes of
bugs it's make it builds on value
semantics and many other nice swift
things
and what this does is allows you to get
way more done with
way less code and now your productivity
as a developer is much higher
right and so that that's really the what
programming languages should be about is
it's not about tabs versus spaces or
curly braces or whatever
it's about how productive do you make
the person and you can only see that
when
you have libraries that were built with
the right intention
that the language was designed for and
with swift i think we're still
a little bit early but swift ui and many
other things that are coming out
now are really showing that and i think
that they're opening people's eyes
it's kind of interesting to think about
like how
that you know the knowledge of something
of how good the bicycle is how people
learn about that
you know so i've used c plus plus now
this is not going to be
a trash talking session about c plus
plus but you see plus plus for a really
long together if you want
i have the scars i feel like i spent
many years without
realizing like there's languages that
could for my particular lifestyle
brain style thinking style there's
languages
that could make me a lot more productive
uh in the debugging stage
in the just the development stage and
thinking like the bicycle for the mind i
can fit
more stuff into my python's a great
example yeah right i mean a machine
learning framework in python is a great
example that
it's just very high abstraction level
and so you can be thinking about things
on a
like very high level algorithmic level
instead of thinking about okay well am i
copying this tensor to a gpu or not
right it's not it's not what you want to
be thinking about
you